at the ground that hosted the first ever
test match a crisis summit to reshape
the uncertain future of cricket
what do you hope to get out of the
meeting today um just clarity and
togetherness i suppose does qriket have
a racism issue
well we've got a lot of work to do
there's no doubt about it
we'll have to resolve it today do you
think it can be resolved today well you
can't resolve it overnight but i'm sure
that uh
accommodation will be reached
the game has been humiliated by the
story of azim rafiq the yorkshire
all-rounder who blew the whistle on
institutional racism azeem rafiq has
shown a light on our game that has
shocked shamed and saddened us all
racism and discrimination
is a blight on our game
our sport did not welcome you
our game did not accept you
as we should have done
we apologize unreservedly for the
suffering
you have faced
to rescue cricket's reputation next week
the ecb has promised to publish a
12-point action plan as a way out of
this racism scandal
this all happened on his watch but the
chief executive of the ecb is determined
to be the one to try and change cricket
from dressing room culture to the
governance of the game and it comes at
the end of a week that has shaken this
sport to its very foundations
yorkshire was a place where even
relatively recently racism was tolerated
and it wasn't a one-off it's left anger
and dismay throughout the game
again i don't think this is just about
cricket this is about wider society
i think our collective aim is to make
sure that our sport reflects
the people and the country that we live
in it's as simple as that
that's what we have to work towards
nottinghamshire player alex hales is the
latest to apologize he's already denied
his dog was named as a racist joke and
now it's a fancy dress party in 2009
where he dressed as us rapper tupac
obviously realizes is incredibly
disrespectful and i want to apologize
for the offense that
this has no doubt caused and it was
incredibly reckless and foolish on my
behalf
and so i want to apologize for that
apologize to the club for the
embarrassment it would have caused them
with regards to the allegations about
the dog there's it's an ongoing
investigation at the club
um so i can't go into detail with that
but i want to reiterate what i said in
my statement um
the other day you know and finally i you
know i deplore
all forms of racism and discrimination
the man at the center of this azim rafiq
has reiterated his apologies for
anti-semitic messages he shared as a 19
year old
nobody in cricket has come out of this
well the game has to change and show
everybody there's no going back
tom parmenter sky news south london